[Music]  oh  [Music]  i told you  yeah  i gotta get that suit  [Music]  [Music]  this is the first christmas we've had  together  in years i love you guys  i'm making up for some lost time  [Music]  authorities are wondering if the masked  vigilante who terrorized the city's  underworld is back  the past has caught up with me  should we be worried no no it's nothing  i'll be home for christmas i promise  [Music]  when i wore this suit  i made a whole lot of enemies  you're a hawkeye who the hell are you  some people have actually called  the world's me  archer  are you one of those people it's the  most wonderful hey babe i should be back  in a day or two  hang on a second  things have gotten  [Music]  more complicated  [Music]  [Applause]  this too dangerous  definitely not this one you'll have to  say definitely like that  holy [ __ ]  there are arrows more dangerous than  that one  [Music]  this is some christmas  [Music]  you